>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME
TO TUCKER CARLSON.
TONIGHT, THE FRUSTRATING THING
ABOUT THE NEWS MEDIA, NO MATTER
HOW HORRIBLE THEY ARE, IS THAT
YOU NEED THEM.
YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND THE WORLD
EXCEPT THROUGH THE NEWS MEDIA.
>> THAT'S FOR ALL OF
OUR INFORMATION COMES FROM.
>> CAN'T REALLY CHANGE THAT AT
THIS POINT, BUT WE CAN GO INTO
IT WITH OPEN EYES.
AND SO YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT
THE THING ABOUT READING
THE NEWS IS EVEN WHEN IT'S NOT
INTENTIONALLY DISHONEST,
AND OFTEN IT IS , NO MATTER
WHAT THE INTENT OF IT,
THE FIRST DRAFT OF THE STORY
THAT YOU READ IS ALWAYS WRONG,
NOT SOMETIMES WRONG, ALWAYS
WRONG.
OCCASIONALLY IN SMALL WAYS,
SOMETIMES IN BIG AND UTTERLY
DISTORTING WAYS.
DEWEY DEFEATS TRUMAN.
IRAQ HAS NUKES.
RUSSIA BOMBED ITS OWN PIPELINE
.
>> STORIES LIKE THIS ARE
LAUGHABLY UNTRUE.
THEY ARE INVERSION OF
THE TRUTH, WHICH INEVITABLY
EMERGES LATER.
AND AT TIMES IT'S
UNINTENTIONAL.
THEY JUST MADE A MISTAKE.
THEY GOT IT WRONG.
BUT MORE OFTEN ON THE BIG
STORIES, THE ONES THAT CHANGE
POLICY, THEY ARE LYING
ON PURPOSE.
SO HOW DO YOU KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE LYING ON PURPOSE OR
WHETHER THEY JUST GOT IT WRONG
BY ACCIDENT?
WELL, WHEN THE STORY TRENDS
ON SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU KNOW THAT
MEANS THAT SOMEWHERE THERE'S
A TECH EXECUTIVE WHO'S DECIDED
TO CRANK UP THE PROPAGANDA IN
ORDER TO MANIPULATE YOU.
IT'S REALLY NOT SO DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT THE NORTH KOREAN
STATE NEWS AGENCY DOES WHEN
THERE'S A FAMINE.
THEY START PROMOTING STORIES
ABOUT RECORD RICE HARVESTS.
>> SO YOU WOULDN'T NOTICE.
SO WITH THAT IN MIND, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN WORTH PAUSING FOR
A MOMENT IN SKEPTICISM WHEN YOU
SAW THAT PHONE, THAT STORY IN
YOUR PHONE YESTERDAY ABOUT
HOW RUSSIA HAD BOMBED POLAND.
>> POLAND IS A MEMBER OF NATO ,
THE NORTH AMERICAN TREATY
ORGANIZATION, SO ARE WE.
THAT MEANS IF RUSSIA WERE
TO ATTACK NATO , THEN WE COULD
VERY EASILY BE OBLIGATED
TO ATTACK RUSSIA BACK .
RUSSIA IS THE LARGEST NUCLEAR
ARSENAL IN THE WORLD.
SO THAT WOULD BE INEVITABLY,
BY DEFINITION, WORLD WAR
THREE .
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE MIGHT DIE.
SO THIS WAS NOT A SMALL STORY.
IT WAS ARCHDUKE FERDINAND IN
SARAJEVO STUFF.
THIS STORY CAME, AS IT SO OFTEN
DOES FROM THE ASSOCIATED PRESS
,CITING AGAIN, AS USUAL,
A QUOTE, UNNAMED SENIOR
US INTEL OFFICIAL.
SO ACCORDING TO THIS UNNAMED
INTEL OFFICIAL, RUSSIA HAD
LAUNCHED AN ENTIRELY UNPROVOKED
FIRST STKE AGAINST POLAND.
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY HAD LOBBED
MISSILES INTO POLISH TERRITORY,
THEREBY KILLING TWO POLES AT
A FARM.
SO BY DEFINITION, IT WAS TIME
FOR EUROPE AND THE US TO INVOKE
ARTICLE FIVE , THE COLLECTIVE
DEFENSE PRINCIPLE, AND BEGIN
A TOTAL WAR ON VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OF
UKRAINE AGREED WITH THIS.
>> THE U.S. MUST DECLARE WAR
ON RUSSIA IN THE WAKE OF THIS
STORY.
>> WATCH HIS REACTION WHEN YOU
STARTED THEN.
>> WHAT WE WARNED ABOUT A LONG
TIME AGO HAPPENED TODAY.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THIS TERROR
IS NOT LIMITED TO OUR NATIONAL
BORDERS.
IT'S ALREADY SPREAD TO THE
TERRITORY OF MOLDOVA AND TODAY
,RUSSIAN MISSILES HIT POLAND,
THE TERRITORY OF FRIENDLY
COUNTRIES, TO FIRE MISSILES AT
NATO TERRITORY.
THIS IS A RUSSIAN MISSILE
ATTACK ON COLLECTIVE SECURITY.
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ESCALATION.
>> WE MUST HAVE.
>> THIS IS A RUSSIAN MISSILE
ATTACK ON COLLECTIVE SECURITY.
IT'S NOT SIMPLY IN POLAND,
ON UKRAINE, BUT ON THE UNITED
STATES IS AN ATTACK ON THE US
BY RUSSIA, END QUOTE.
>> WE MUST ACT.
SO THIS A MAN WITH SOME MORAL
AUTHORITY.
THIS IS THE ONLY HEAD OF STATE
IN THE WORLD TO RECEIVE A VOGUE
PHOTO SPREAD THIS YEAR.
>> THIS IS A PERSONAL FRIEND OF
SEAN PENN AND BEN STILLER'S.
>> AND HERE HE WAS COMMANDING
THE U.S. TO LEAD THE THIRD
WORLD WAR IMMEDIATELY.
>> SO AS WE SAID, THIS WAS NOT
A MINOR AP STORY.
>> THE ONLY PROBLEM WAS IT WAS
COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY WRONG.
ZELENSKYY, THE UNNAMED AMERICAN
INTEL OFFICER AND THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS HAD ALL BEEN
TRAFFICKING IN DANGEROUS
MISINFORMATION THAT BECAME
CLEAR WITHIN A FEW HOURS WHEN
PICTURES OF THE EXPLODED
MISSILE SURFACED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
PEOPLE KNOW A LOT ABOUT
MILITARY HARDWARE STARTED
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
STUFF.
SO THEY LOOKED AT A PICTURE OF
A FRAGMENT OF THE MOTOR FROM
THIS DESTROYED MISSILE AND THEY
NOTICED THE ORDINANCE WAS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED SYSTEM.
NOW, THE THREE HUNDRED SYSTEM
IS ONLY BEING USED BY THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY, NOT
THE RUSSIANS.
SO IT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
A RUSSIAN MILITARY ATTACK
SOMEHOW.
UKRAINE HAD BOMBED POLAND
AND KILLED PEOPLE.
THAT'S TRUE.
AND WITHIN A DAY, THE PENTAGON
,NATO AND EVEN THE GOVERNMENT
OF POLAND ALL WERE FORCED
TO ADMIT THAT THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> UKRAINE DID IT.
BUT HERE'S THE INTERESTING
THING.
THE THING THAT IS RELEVANT
TO US, UKRAINE NEVER ADMITTED
THAT ZELENSKYY KEPT LYING
ON TELEVISION.
SO WHEN YOU WERE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE THE FREE PRESS HAS BEEN
BANNED, AS IT HAS BEEN IN
UKRAINE, YOU MAY NOT REALIZE
THAT THE REST OF THE WORLD
IS NOT REQUIRED TO BELIEVE YOU.
YOU CAN'T THROW THEM IN JAIL.
SO HE KEPT TELLING YOU WHAT YOU
KNEW IS NOT TRUE.
QUOTE, I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
THIS IS NOT OUR MISSILE.
HE SAID TODAY.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS
A RUSSIAN MISSILE BASED
ON MILITARY REPORTS.
>> AGAIN, THAT'S NOT
ONLY UNTRUE, IT'S A LIE THAT
COULD GET MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
KILLED.
>> SO YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF
,IS IT TIME TO STOP BACKING
THIS GUY?
COULD THE RISK BE TOO HIGH?
HE'S LYING ON PURPOSE TO GET
US INTO A WAR.
MAYBE HE'S NOT WORTH SUPPORTING
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
MAYBE HE'S JUST OTHER CORRUPT
EASTERN EUROPEAN STRONGMEN IN
A TRACKSUIT GETTING AS RICH
AS HE CAN FROM AMERICAN
HANDOUTS.
THAT MIGHT BE THE LESSON, BUT
THAT IS NOT AT ALL THE LESSON
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS DRAWING FROM WHAT JUST
HAPPENED.
WATCH FORMER RAYTHEON BOARD
MEMBER LLOYD AUSTIN EXPLAIN
THAT EVEN IF THE MISSILE ATTACK
WAS FROM UKRAINE, IT'S STILL
RUSSIA'S FAULT.
>> THIS EXPLOSION WAS MOST
LIKELY THE RESULT OF
A UKRAINIAN AIR DEFENSE MISSILE
THAT UNFORTUNATELY LANDED IN
POLAND.
AND WHATEVER THE FINAL
CONCLUSIONS MAY BE , THE WORLD
KNOWS THAT RUSSIA BEARS
ULTIMATE RESPONSE.
>> THE ABILITY FOR THIS
INCIDENT.
>> SO THIS IS NOT WHAT WE WOULD
REFER TO AS EVIDENCE BASED
REASONING.
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
IS THAT UKRAINE LOBBED
A MISSILE INTO POLAND
AND KILLED POLES.
BUT YOU NEED TO CONTINUE
TO SEND BILLIONS TO UKRAINE
TO FIGHT RUSSIA.
SO NOW YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE
WHY THE UNNAMED INTEL OFFICIAL
LEAKED THIS STORY TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THIS MANUFACTURED STORY.
AND THE POINT, OF COURSE, WAS
TO MANIPULATE THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS AS SO OFTEN
HAPPEN.
UNNAMED AMERICAN INTEL OFFICIAL
LEAKS SOMETHING TO THE
"NEW YORK TIMES", WASHINGTON
POST, AP MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
READ THIS AND DO WHAT THE INTEL
AGENCIES AND THE ADMINISTRATION
WANT THEM TO DO.
>> AND WE CAN ALL BUT PROVE
THAT IN THIS CASE, BECAUSE
SHORTLY AFTER THIS FAKE NEWS OF
THIS FAKE RUSSIAN MISSILE
ATTACK, APPEARED IN THE AP
WIRE, THE WHITE HOUSE DEMANDED
ANOTHER THIRTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR UKRAINE
SO THAT RAISES THE QUESTION,
WHERE DOES THAT PUT US ?
WHAT'S THE TOTAL THAT WE'VE
SENT TO UKRAINE?
SO FAR ?
WELL, IN JUST NINE MONTHS,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
COMMITTED A TOTAL OF
NINETY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
TO UKRAINE AT A TIME WHEN
OUR BORDERS STILL OPEN AND OUR
ECONOMY IS DEGRADING FAST.
>> SO HOW MUCH IS THAT?
WELL, AS GLENN GREENWALD
POINTED OUT TODAY,
NINETY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IS TWICE THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
US EXPENDITURE DURING OUR OWN
WAR IN AFGHANISTAN, 91 BILLION
DOLLARS IS THIRTY THREE PERCENT
MORE THAN THE ENTIRE ANNUAL
MILITARY BUDGET OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY OF RUSSIA.
BUT NOT ENOUGH.
TODAY, MARK MILLEY INFORMED
US THAT NINETY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> THE UNITED STATES ARE
DETERMINED TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT UKRAINE WITH THE
MEANS TO DEFEND THEMSELVES FOR
AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE FOR AS LONG AS IT
TAKES, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THEM AS LONG AS IT
TAKES.
AND UNTIL THEN, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT ALL
THE WAY FOR AS LONG AS IT TAKES
.
>> WE WILL BE THERE FOR AS LONG
AS IT TAKES.
SO THERE YOU HAVE THE OBEDIENT
LITTLE GENERAL READING
THE TALKING POINTS AGAIN.
BUT STILL DOESN'T ANSWER
THE QUESTION WHY?
>> AS LONG AS IT TAKES OKAY,
SOME THINGS ARE WORTH THAT
COMMITMENT.
BUT WHY THIS ONE ?
WHAT IS THE POINT OF THIS
EXACTLY?
WE CAN'T SAY WE'RE DEFENDING
DEMOCRACY IN UKRAINE, WHICH
IS NOT A DEMOCRATIC COUNTRY.
WE CAN'T EXPLAIN CLEARLY OR
EVEN AT ALL WHERE OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY INTEREST LIES IN THIS
CONFLICT BETWEEN TWO EASTERN
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES.
>> SO WHY WOULD WE BANKRUPT
OURSELVES TO FUND IT?
COULD IT BE THAT THIS ENTIRE
EFFORT IS A CHOREOGRAPHED SCAM?
TO ENRICH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND ITS ALLIES AND ACHIEVE LEFT
WING IDEOLOGICAL GOALS THAT
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CORE INTERESTS OF THE UNITED
STATES ?
>> COULD IT BE THIS THIS WHOLE
THING IS BLM, EASTERN EUROPEAN
EDITION ?
>> WELL, IT'S POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THAT IS HOW WASHINGTON
ACTUALLY WORKS.
AND THE BREWING SCANDAL KIND OF
EXPOSES THAT YOU MAY HAVE
READ ABOUT.
THIS IS THE CRYPTOCURRENCY
EXCHANGE THAT JUST BLEW UP IN
ONE OF THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ONE DAY LOSSES IN WORLD
HISTORY, POSSIBLY THE BIGGEST
EVER.
NOW, WHAT WAS FDX?
IT WASN'T A CONVENTIONAL
BUSINESS.
NO, IN FACT, IT WAS THE FINANCE
ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND BACK SCRATCHING THE SNAKE
EATING ITS TAIL IS ON FULL
DISPLAY IN THIS STORY.
SO DEMOCRATS INVITED FAUCI CEOS
EMBANKMENT BANK BEEN FREED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TO DISCUSS,
DISCUSS CRYPTO REGULATION.
SO THE PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE KEEPING THIS BUSINESS
WITHIN.
THE LINES WERE
ACTUALLY COLLUDING WITH THE
BUSINESS AND DOING NOTHING
TO KEEP IT FROM DEFRAUDING ITS
INVESTORS.
AND THEN IN CONGRESS, IS ALSO
SUPPOSED TO BE OVERSEEING
THE FINANCE SECTOR.
MAXINE.
WATERS, WHO CHAIRS
THE FINANCIAL SERVICES
COMMITTEE, WAS PALLING AROUND
WITH SAM BANKS AND SHE TOOK
THE PICTURE WITH HIM.
YOU'RE SEEING ON YOUR SCREEN
NOW THAT PICTURE WAS TAKEN
AFTER THE FIRST EVER HEARING
ON CRYPTO REGULATIONS.
SO THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD DEAL .
YOU'RE RUNNING A SCAM AND THE
REGULATORS ARE ON YOUR SIDE.
HOW DO YOU KEEP THEM ON YOUR
SIDE?
WELL, IF YOU'RE BANK BEEN
FREED , YOU DONATE NEARLY
40 BILLION DOLLARS TO DEMOCRATS
IN THE MIDTERM, WHICH HE DID.
AND THAT TOTAL PUTS HIM NUMBER
TWO ON THE DONOR LIST RIGHT
BELOW GEORGE SOROS.
NOW, THAT'S SO OBVIOUSLY
ILLEGAL.
AND WRONG AND CORRUPT THAT
YOU'D PROBABLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE NOBODY WROTE ABOUT IT.
AND THAT'S WHY I SAY I'M BANK,
BEEN FREED , ALSO BOUGHT OFF
THE MEDIA.
HE HANDED MILLIONS TO PLACES
LIKE VOX, THE INTERCEPT
SEMIFORMAL, PROPUBLICA
AND PROBABLY MANY OTHERS.
>> SO WITH TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVAPORATING INTO THIN
AIR AND SAM BANK AND FREED, NOT
EVEN WITHIN THE BORDERS OF
THE UNITED STATES TONIGHT,
THE QUESTION IS WHERE INVESTORS
LEFT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BIG
RETIREMENT FUNDS WERE INVESTED
IN THIS THING IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IN CANADA.
WILL THEY GET ANY OF
THEIR MONEY BACK ?
WHAT ABOUT THE MONEY?
THAT SAME BANK AND FREED GAVE
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
WILL THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO GIVE
IT BACK TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEFRAUDED?
WILL THE MEDIA COMPANIES THAT
TOOK IT SEMAPHORE, FOR EXAMPLE,
HAVE TO GIVE IT BACK TO THE
PEOPLE WHOSE MONEY WAS
EFFECTIVELY STOLEN?
WELL, MAXINE WATERS WAS
A BENEFICIARY OF THIS, AND SHE
WAS ASKED TODAY WHETHER
SHE'S RETURNING ANY OF THESE
DONATIONS.
FOX IS HILARY VAUGHN JUST
CAUGHT UP WITH WATERS AND SHE
MADE IT VERY CLEAR , OF COURSE,
SHE'S KEEPING THE MONEY.
DO YOU THINK SOME LAWMAKERS
THAT GOT DONATIONS FROM FAUCI
FOUNDER SHOULD GIVE THAT MONEY
BACK ?
OH, WELL, I DON'T WANT TO GET
INTO THAT AS A MATTER OF FACT,
BOTH DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
HAVE RECEIVED DONATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
YEAH.
YEAH, EVERYONE DID.
ACTUALLY , EVERYONE DIDN'T DO
IT.
THIS WAS THE FINANCE ARM OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, ONE OF
THE BIGGEST STORIES OF
THE YEAR.
MAYBE THE LAST TEN YEARS.
WE'RE GOING HAVE A LOT MORE ON
IT TOMORROW AND IN THE WEEKS
TO COME.
BUT WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IT
TONIGHT?
WE'RE TELLING YOU ABOUT IT
BECAUSE YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT
FAUCI X WAS ALSO IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE.
BECAUSE ALL THREADS RETURNED
TO THE SAME SCHOOL.
>> IT'D BE INTERESTING TO KNOW
HOW MUCH MONEY, IF ANY, UKRAINE
FUNNELED BACK TO FAUCI, WHICH
THEN WOUND UP IN THE HANDS OF
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR CONGRESS
IN THIS LAST CYCLE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
>> AN AUDIT MIGHT TELL US THERE
HAS BEEN NO AUDIT TODAY IN
THE HOUSE.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE HAS BEEN
DEMANDING AN AUDIT, BUT TO NO
AVAIL SO FAR .
>> AND THAT MEANS THAT TENS OF
BILLIONS OF YOUR TAX DOLLARS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
SHOVELED TO THE GOVERNMENT OF
UKRAINE REMAIN, AS OF TONIGHT,
COMPLETELY UNACCOUNTED FOR.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE MONEY.
AND STILL THE UKRAINIANS ARE
DEMANDING MORE AND TRYING
TO GET US INTO A WORLD WAR THAT
WOULD BENEFIT US IN NO WAY
A REPUBLICAN SUPPORTING THIS
COULD ANY REPUBLICAN POSSIBLY
SUPPORT THIS MORE MO